Hey, Craig Foster.
Yeah. I'm sorry.
Who are you?
Natalie Ray Boone.
My family works down the road.
You ever heard of carpets?
Yeah, the old strip club.
Yeah, that's our place.
We are closed down in this goodwill
hunting ass stripper. Started to poke
around in our Texas.
Mm. You wanna come with me?
I want to talk to you about a business
proposition.
Wow, that's flattering.
And as much as everything about your
vibe seems normal, I'm actually really
busy right now.
I wasn't asking.
Welcome to carpets where the only
carpet. Is on the floor.
Seriously, Ray? Nathan.
Who's this? Oh, this is our neighbor.
Mom told me. Go get. Well, nobody told
me. Oh, I told you.
You just don't listen to me.
And you're always looking at your
phone.
The group chat doesn't care if I'm busy.
When it pops off, it pops off.
Hey, you're busy. I can come back
another time. You can call me.
Probably. Good for him to see who he's
dealing with. This gentleman here.
He was supposed to deliver some
merchandise for us drugs, and that
merchandise mysteriously went missing.
He did the drugs.
Damn it, Natty, I'm trying to be
evocative here.
You got no mystique.
That's why you're still single.
I'm single because I work all the time.
Now.
This.
Is what happens.
When somebody messes with our
merchandise.
Hell no. Nobody f**** with the booms.
Come on.
What the hell? Why isn't he hungry?
Huh? Did you feed the gator?
Well, the
thing about Buttercup.
Don't name.
Him. And definitely not Buttercup.
Okay, First of all, it is a girl because
she is pretty. And, yes, I gave her a
treat. If we want her to be sweet, we
have to give her a treat to be sweet.
Want her to be sweet?
She's an alligator. She's supposed to
be scary. You know what's.
Scary is when a cutie doesn't get her
train. Hello?
Hey. Leave it.
Leave it. I'm Jackie
Boone and these are my children.
We have a business proposal for you.
I think there's been some kind of
mistake. I just only saw Palmetto Farm.
Yeah, we know.
We used to run the Saw Palmetto Berry
game. Yeah, we'd pick on public land
and sell to the supplement companies.
Easy money.
It's the best kind of money.
Yeah, but.
They cut us out by bribing the state to
change the laws.
Now you have to own the land where you
get your berries.
The supplement companies bought up all
the swamp land.
So here's what we're proposing.
We recently picked a bunch of berries
out in the Everglades.
We would like to say that them berries
come from your farm.
You sell them.
We split the profits.
80 / 20.
So you want to launder your berries
through my farm?
You make it sound unseemly.
We're just small business owners, just
like you.
What happens if I say no?
Well, that's a conversation you can have
with Buttercup over there.
Mother F It's the treats.
It's not the treats.
She's. She just relaxed because we're
all together. This is.
Definitely intriguing, but um.
I just worked so hard to get where I am,
I'd rather just keep it above board.
Man. With a code.
I can respect that.
You wanna drive Mr. Foster back to his
farm.